en el último vídeo vimos que las dos
figuras de silla con formaciones de
silla de la molécula del ciclo hexano
eran igualmente estables verdad no
habían y no había razón alguna que nos
implicará que alguna fuera más estable
que la otra o viceversa verdad así que
lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es es
atender la cuestión de qué ocurre si en
vez de solo el ciclo hexano tenemos en
realidad un grupo radical ahí metido
vamos a ponerle un grupo metilo ok
entonces en vez de tener solo el ciclo
hexano vamos a tener un metil
ciclohexano y recordemos que cuando
decimos metil ciclohexano como sólo es
un una digamos una ramificación no es
necesario decir en que carbono se
encuentra entonces digamos que aquí
tenemos un grupo metilo muy bien
entonces aquí tenemos nuestro metil
me till ciclo hexano muy bien y por
supuesto recordemos que cuando tenemos
el metil ciclohexano en realidad aquí
estamos pensando que aquí hay un carbono
y aquí hay otros tres hidrógenos verdad
este es nuestro ch3 entonces cómo se
vería esto en nuestra representación de
tipo silla pues en vez de tener este
hidrógeno digamos aquí era un carbono y
tendríamos otros dos hidrógenos o que se
yo en vez de este hidrógeno vamos a
tener un c
h3 verdad tenemos un c
h3
lo mismo si quisiéramos representarlo en
la otra en la otra estructura pues
tendríamos aquí en vez de este hidrógeno
tendríamos un c
h 3 verdad entonces así es cómo cambian
estas moléculas ahora para poder
trabajar bien con esto vamos a enumerar
los carbonos de nuestro ciclo de 6
carbonos entonces ahí tenemos enumerados
del 1 al 6 aquí vamos déjenme ponerlo
con blanco para que sea más claro este
es el 1 2 3 4 5 y 6 y aquí va a ser el 1
2 3 4 5 y 6 y recordemos que siempre
empezamos a enumerar justo en donde
aparece nuestra única ramificación que
es bueno que para este caso sólo tenemos
una ramificación verdad entonces ya que
hemos hecho este cambio ya vimos cómo se
ven nuestras representaciones y ya vamos
a tratar de ver cuál cuál sería digamos
la proyección de newman porque realmente
la pregunta que queremos responder en
este vídeo es cuál de estas dos
configuraciones va a ser la más estable
y a lo mejor puedes echarle un ojo a
este diagrama y decir bueno cuando nos
encontramos en esta posición
déjenme ver
si por ejemplo tenemos este este grupo
metilo cuando se encuentra en grupo en
perdonen en digamos en una configuración
o en una posición axial a lo mejor
podría pensar que ya sabes con toda esta
cuestión de las nubes de electrones y
demás que que a lo mejor éste va a estar
mucho más cerca de los otros carbonos
verdad que se encuentran
a lo mejor justamente por encontrarse
más cerca de estos carbonos pues a lo
mejor tendrá muchas digamos va a repeler
sé mucho más debido a que se encuentran
más cerca de las nubes de los de los
electrones verdad y bueno para poder ver
esto en realidad tenemos que checar o
más bien nos puede ayudar mucho diseñar
una especie de proyecciones de newman
doble para poder ver cuál es la
configuración más estable ok
en realidad los diagramas de newman no
solo son útiles para cosas simples como
el butano o el metano sino también
podemos utilizarlo para los anillos
cíclicos y para hacer el diagrama de
newman
ya que tenemos enumerados los carbonos
ahora vamos a determinar a partir de
cual vamos a empezar a ver digamos cuál
sería el del frente cuál sería el de
atrás y pero vamos a hacerlo en unos
minutos
entonces para para comenzar nuestro
nuestro diagrama de newman vamos a
digamos elegir nuestro primer carbono
este va a ser nuestro primer carbono y
ese va a ser el que vemos de frente muy
bien este va a ser el que vemos de
frente y por supuesto este segundo
carbono va a ser el que veamos por
detrás entonces ya que tenemos elegido
nuestro primer carbono entonces tenemos
digamos en una posición axial tenemos
ch3
muy bien déjenme déjenme ponerle un
poquito mejor déjenme ponerle un poquito
mejor porque queda un poco seco entonces
tenemos nuestro ch3 en posición axial y
tenemos en en posición ecuatorial este
hidrógeno verdad aquí tenemos este
hidrógeno y si nos damos cuenta este se
une al carbono 6 verdad de esta forma se
une al carbono 6 pero este carbono 6 en
realidad es todo un grupo verdad es un
ch 2 podemos pensarlo como todo un grupo
completito verdad entonces este va a ser
importante enumerar lo este es el número
6 ahora ponemos nuestro carbono del
fondo que es el carbono número 2 verdad
recordemos que es este carbono de aquí y
por lo tanto esto significa que esta
molécula digamos la estamos viendo por
acá verdad estamos viéndolo como en esta
perspectiva ok entonces ya que tenemos
este de atrás que es lo que sabemos pues
que justamente
tenemos este estos dos hidrógenos verdad
tenemos estos dos hidrógenos este de
aquí y este de aquí digamos unidos de
esta forma que está en estos dos
hidrógenos y finalmente tenemos unido a
nuestro tercer carbono verdad entonces
tenemos este enlace este enlace hacia
nuestro tercer carbono déjenme circular
lo digamos así para que quede claro que
a final de cuentas es un ch 2 verdad
aquí por supuesto nos falta poner el
otro hidrógeno y demás pero bueno este
es un c h 2 y este es el carbono número
3 verdad hay que hay que solo hay que
tener en cuenta eso ahora bien este se
está uniendo al cuarto y el sexto se
está uniendo al quinto entonces vamos a
elegir nuevamente alguno de ellos de
hecho tendría que ser el quinto verdad
si nosotros vemos la molécula desde esta
perspectiva pues va adelante el quinto
carbono y atrás el cuarto entonces vamos
a poner nuestro quinto carbono vamos a
a elegirlo con vamos a ponerlo con verde
entonces aquí tenemos nuestro puntito
que es nuestro quinto carbono verdad y
atrás de él va a estar el cuarto carbono
muy bien pero en el quinto carbono que
es lo que tenemos que se une al sexto
verdad tenemos esta unión
digamos esta unión morada que se une al
sexto y también tenemos un hidrógeno
vamos a ponerlo con rosa aquí tenemos
nuestro hidrógeno y que otra cosa
también tenemos que se une
o claro es que es que en el otro vídeo
ya no termine de pintarlos verdad
entonces se une también al otro
hidrógeno tenemos a otro hidrógeno ahora
detrás de éste se encuentra nuestro
carbono 4 vamos a ponerlo digamos así ok
y este carbono 4 a quien está unido pues
este carbono 4 tiene dos hidrógenos
vamos a ponerlo aquí un hidrógeno y
tenemos el otro hidrógeno por acá y
finalmente este cuarto carbono se une al
tercero verdad se une al tercero de esta
forma y ahí lo tienen tenemos un
diagrama de newman o una proyección de
newman doble para representar este ciclo
al ciclo ciclohexano entonces a partir
de este diagrama podemos inmediatamente
observar que este grupo sea
este grupo ch3 este digamos de aquí está
unido a este ese h 2 por un ángulo de 60
grados verdad entonces quiere decir que
este digamos éste metil que que están en
posición axial digamos vamos a poner
en posición axial se encuentra a 60
grados del ch 2 correspondiente al
carbono número 3 quiere decir en
realidad que esta conformación se
encuentra en realidad es conformación de
ghanuchi o bueno no sé bien cómo se
pronuncia creo que suena como francés
era como go o algo así pero es es
conformación gaucho respecto al número 3
verdad vamos a ponerle aquí respecto al
carbono número 3 ok entonces vamos a ver
qué pasaría si nosotros dibujamos el
diagrama o la proyección de newman para
la otra conformación silla que vamos a
movernos un poquito a la derecha y
nuevamente pues vamos a elegir nuestro
primer nuestro primer carbono que sería
el 1 ok y detrás de él estaría el 2
verdad entonces en el primero que es lo
que tenemos tenemos unido el ch 3
y aquí ya se encuentra en posición
ecuatorial aquí está nuestro ch3 y
también está unido a quien éstos
aquí me faltan 12 y aquí tenemos que
está unido a éste sh2 y a este hidrógeno
verdad entonces está unido a este
déjenme ponerlo con azul verdad porque
este sh2 lo pusimos con azul que
entonces está unido al
h 2 y también está unido a este
hidrógeno verdad está unido a este
hidrógeno muy bien ahora qué pasa con el
segundo carbono lo tienen vamos a poner
este segundo carbono por detrás
justamente recuerden que es digamos la
perspectiva es de esta forma verdad
estamos viendo en esa dirección entonces
el segundo carbono está unido a quien
está unido a dos hidrógenos verdad vamos
a poner esos dos hidrógenos no sé aquí
este este primer hidrógeno aquí vamos a
poner el otro hidrógeno y además está
unido a nuestro
a nuestro carbono número
ok quizás para para verlo bueno más bien
vamos a enumerar lo este era el número 6
verdad este es el número 6 y para unirlo
al carbón un número 3 estamos uniendo
digamos de esta forma verdad aquí está
el ch3 y este es el número 3 de nuestra
cadena verdad entonces ahora tenemos que
considerar si estamos viendo en esta
dirección entonces el quinto nuevamente
vuelve a ser digamos el de enfrente
verdad vamos a poner este con rojo
también este va a ser nuestro carbono 5
y el carbono 5 está unido a sus dos
hidrógenos aquí falta poner sus dos
hidrógenos
vamos a ponerlos de esta forma aquí
tenemos uno en uno es axial el otro es
ecuatorial y después lo ponemos unido al
sexto carbono que es éste sh2 verdad que
quedó un poco largo vamos a ponerlo de
esta forma ahora ponemos por atrás el
carbono 4 aquí tenemos nuestro carbono 4
que ahí está el carbono 4 y vamos a
poner los otros enlaces que tiene este
carbono 4 está unido a dos hidrógenos
ahí tienen su hidrógeno axial el
hidrógeno ecuatorial y está unido a éste
sh 3 muy bien entonces ahora si pensemos
recordemos que estamos analizando este
ch3 este grupo ch3 que tiene una gran
conglomeración de electrones y si nos
damos cuenta en este caso tenemos una un
ángulo de 180 grados con respecto al
número 3 verdad aquí tenemos un ángulo
de 180 grados y si nos fijamos en el
otro ch2 que es el siguiente que importa
aquí tenemos 120 grados verdad 120
grados entonces qué es lo que tenemos
aquí esto en realidad nos está diciendo
que tenemos una conformación anti esta
es una conformación
en ti
en ti pero con respecto al número 3
verdad con respecto al número 3 en el
otro caso teníamos una conformación
gaucho ok entonces con esto podemos ver
que esta molécula de aquí o más bien
esta conformación si ya la la que
corresponde a cuando el ch 3 del grupo
metilo está en una posición ecuatorial
es más estable ésta es más estable éste
es más estable
de hecho podremos ver que si
relacionamos este grupo metilo con
respecto al carbono número 6 en este
caso tenemos 120 grados verdad entonces
realmente en donde le ganamos en ese es
en este ángulo entre el primero y el
tercero entonces
ahora espero que realmente hayas
encontrado esto interesante y que hayas
encontrado esta forma como como un
ejercicio digamos para poder visualizar
más estos diagramas dobles de newman y
que te resulte más sencilla la forma en
que en que podríamos pensar cómo
visualizar estos diagramas justo para
ciclo alcanos ok todo el punto de visa
lizar estos ciclos arcanos es fijarnos
sobre todo en la perspectiva en la que
estamos viendo por ejemplo para este
primer caso veíamos desde digamos en
esta dirección mientras que en el
segundo caso veíamos en esta dirección
el resto sale solito